[Musica]
un giorno mi stavo riposando all'interno
della Chiesa di Sant'Andrea al Quirinale
a Roma attorno a me nessuno solo il
silenzio ad un certo punto entrano due
bambini che come folgorati dalla
bellezza esclamano Che meraviglia Per me
quello è stato un tuffo al cuore
ritornare bambino e ho pensato questi
bimbi sono davvero fortunati la
meraviglia generata dalla natura e
dall'arte è il frutto della mia storia
familiare e di tutte le cose che mi sono
passate sotto gli occhi da bambino e
proprio per questo penso che i bambini
abbiano il diritto di sperimentare la
meraviglia che è fonte di energia
creativa per i bambini la meraviglia È
lì a portata di mano basta un fiore un
albero quindi penso che i genitori
debbano educare i propri figli alla
meraviglia affinché essi la possano
sperimentare Ma che cos'è la meraviglia
la meraviglia È uno stato da animo
generato da tantissime cose un atto
eroico un atto sportivo una bellezza
naturale e mentre la osserviamo nella
nostra testa ci chiediamo posso con i
miei occhi realizzare tutto ciò che sto
vedendo in questo momento lo stato
meraviglioso può essere generato da
tantissime cose ma io mi voglio
soffermare su quello generato dalla
bellezza che personalmente mi
riguarda sono nato a Noto non so se la
conoscete una cittadina del Sudest
siciliano che è stata ricostruita
totalmente dopo il terremoto più forte
mai registrato in Italia il terremoto di
Catania nel gennaio del
1693 e gli architetti dell'epoca
decisero di ricostruirla con lo stile
attuale ovvero il Barocco barocco e
meraviglia possono considerarsi
a tutti gli effetti dei sinonimi ma non
decisero di ricostruirla con il Barocco
ricco come quello di inizio seic
decisero di ricostruirla con un barocco
che si avvicinava alle sue forme
classiche vicino al neoclassico appunto
noto è stata costruita durante il
setc la potenza di Noto sta
nell'eleganza delle sue architetture
nell'uniformità del suo impianto
urbanistico invece nella Sicilia
occidentale in forma più assoluta a
Palermo troviamo l'espressione di
barocco più ricca e più piena
un'esperienza che secondo me bisogna
fare è entrare all'interno della Chiesa
dei Gesuiti di Palermo meglio detta Casa
Professa quando ci troveremo di fronte
alla chiesa ci troveremo di fronte ad
una facciata elegante sont cosa che non
ci farà minimamente capire cosa ci
troveremo all'interno ovvero tre
un ampio presbiterio e le cappelle
laterali totalmente adornate da
ornamenti marmorei fatti di Marmi Mischi
e tram Mischi sculture che hanno
richiesto l'operato di artigiani e
architetti per centinaia di anni
un'altra esperienza che vi consiglio di
fare è visitare la chiesa dei Gesuiti
sempre Gesuiti grandi mecenati a Roma
vicino Piazza Venezia come centro di
interesse principale troviamo l'affresco
della navata centrale ovvero il trionfo
del nome di Gesù realizzato dal pittore
famoso per all'epoca molto amico di
Bernini ovvero Giovan Battista gaulli
detto il baciccio e non c'è foto e video
fatto bene che riesca a restituire lo
stesso effetto di tridimensionalità e di
meraviglia che avremo quando lo
osserviamo Ad occhi nudi il pittore ci
suggerisce una nuova ione del Divino
sembra che all'interno della chiesa si
sia aperta una fessura verso il paradiso
non c'è più distacco tra terreno e
ultraterreno e anche con i migliori
visori 3D che oggi abbiamo sul commercio
Non riusciremo ad avere lo stesso
effetto di tridimensionalità e di
meraviglia ma non solo fa questo la
meraviglia ma risveglia emozioni che
abbiamo perso crescendo
e
ci fa risvegliare il nostro io bambino
tutte queste cose anim tutte queste cose
animano la mia attività comunicativa sui
social che è volta a far uscire le
persone fuori di casa e a scoprire la
meraviglia che ci circonda certo vedere
una chiesa è sicuramente più faticoso
più dispendioso e a livello di tempo più
impegnativo di aprire Instagram entrare
sul mio profilo e vedere un mio video ma
sicuramente sarete interessati a farlo
di fronte ai benefici che avrete e il
discorso dei benefici non è non sono
solo chiacchiere da bar chiacchiere tra
amici ma un importante rapporto fatto
dall'oms ovvero l'organizzazione
Mondiale della sanità che attesta i
benefici dell'arte sulla
salute le telecamere del programma TV
Rai generazione bellezza sono entrate
all'interno della basilica di Santa
Croce laddove dal perse i sensi a causa
dell'eccessiva esposizione alla bellezza
per documentare tutto ciò e hanno notato
di come un'eccessiva esposizione alla
bellezza fa abbassare i livelli di
cortisolo che è l'ormone dello stress e
fa alzare i livelli dell'ossitocina
ovvero il cosiddetto ormone
dell'amicizia Il sistema sanitario
inglese ha definito col termine Heart of
prescription la somministrazione di
visite in luoghi d'arte musei beni
culturali al posto della
somministrazione di
psicofarmaci Questa terapia è funzionata
anche su di me appunto mi ha salvato in
un periodo dove non trovavo equilibrio
il periodo post pandemico e può
risollevare anche voi Quindi sono sicuro
che se fate crescere i vostri bambini in
un ambiente pieno d'arte e di meraviglia
Cresceranno in maniera più armonica e i
genitori rimarranno in salute sia nel
corpo che nella mente
[Applauso]
Grazie